CHADE-MENG TAN: My friends,
thanks for being here.
We are honored today to
host somebody who I
look up to, Ping Fu.
Ping Fu is an admired 3D pioneer
and a remarkably
successful entrepreneur.
As co-founder and CEO of
Geomagic, she was named Inc.
Magazine's entrepreneur
of the year in 2005.
Before co-founding Geomagic,
she managed the team that
created NCSA Mosaic, which
later became the Netscape
browser, which of course gave
us the internet boom.
So Ping was there right
at the beginning of
the internet boom.
And with a name like Ping, sort
of expect to be involved
in internet.
Sorry.
Engineer joke for those
on YouTube.
Ping was also named an
Outstanding American by
Choice, and she advises the
White House on innovation and
entrepreneurship.
But more than her success and
her talents, what I most
admire about Ping is how she
deals with adversity after
adversity in her life with
amazing resilience and, more
importantly, kindness
and compassion.
Her new book, her latest book,
is an autobiography, "Bend,
Not Break," available in Google
Play and all other
major bookstores.
In the next hour, Ping and I
will talk about the exciting
world of 3D technology and
Ping's fascinating life story.
And with that, let's
welcome Ping Fu.
[APPLAUSE]
CHADE-MENG TAN: Thank
you for being here.
So happy to have you.
PING FU: Pleasure to be here.
CHADE-MENG TAN: So let me begin
with a question, Ping.
You live a fascinating life.
But if you were to boil down
your life story to a few
sentences, how will
you describe it?
PING FU: Well, my life is really
truly a American story,
American dream story.
I would say I lived
three lives--
CHADE-MENG TAN: For
the price of one.
PING FU: --for the price
of one, yes.
Maybe I'm writing the next
chapter of the life.
I lived in China during Cultural
Revolution, and then
being exiled, and I arrived
in the United States as
fresh-off-boat, poor
immigrants try to
look for a new life.
And I did gone through all the
new immigration story, and
then later start a business and
become an entrepreneur.
So that's why I said there's
three chapters of my life.
But really, it shows the human
spirit of adoptability to
change and of the power
of resilience.
CHADE-MENG TAN: You're
very modest.
You describe your life as fairly
normal, but your life
is extraordinary.
And I'll give you a sense of
how extraordinary it is.
So when I read your book, the
first few chapters made me
want to cry.
Your early life, to me,
was horrendous.
You were taken away from your
parents at the age of eight
and then you had to fend for
yourself and your baby sister,
Hong, at the time, at
eight years old.
And then you were gang-raped
at 10.
You were hungry, you were
beaten, were abused, endlessly
abused for years.
And then as an adult, you were
thrown into prison for
documenting female
infanticide.
And then you were exiled
from your own country.
And then, as if that's not bad
enough, you were writing in
the United States and your first
experience in the US was
getting kidnapped.
And what I want to
know is this--
So first, I'd like to invite you
to tell us, the audience,
about your early experience
in your own words.
And more importantly, I want
to know how you managed to
preserve your goodness, your
kindness, your compassion
despite such a horrible
experience.
PING FU: Thank you, Meng.
That's a very mindful
question.
So let me first bring
you back to 1966.
That was at the time of China's
infamous Cultural
Revolution.
Mao decided to turn the country
upside down so all
school were closed.
I was eight years old.
I was raised by my aunt and
uncle who I thought was my
biological parents.
And I had five older siblings,
and I was the youngest one in
the family.
So one day, I heard noise
down in our courtyard.
I already knew the country's
kind of turned upside down, so
I saw they came for my mother,
who was my aunt, But
they came for me.
And that was the day that the
Red Guard coming to our house
and told me that my mother
was not my mother.
And I was screaming and crying
and I said, no, no, no.
You're lying.
I tell my mother,
you're lying.
I am your child.
Just a week ago, you told
me I was your favorite.
And I wasn't even given the
chance to give her a hug when
I was ripped away from the only
family that I knew and
put on a train from Shanghai
South Station to send to
Nanjing which is where my
biological parents lived.
And I arrived just a little
bit too late.
When I arrived in Nanjing, all
I saw was big dusts on the
street, thousands of
people, chaos.
You can smell blood.
And my biological parents were
put on a truck being taken
away, sent far, far
away in exile.
And my mother, on the back of
truck, screamed out my name,
Ping, please take care
of your sister.
And a little bit later of that
day, I was put into a
dormitory, led to the second
floor of a room.
There, I found my little
sister, four years old.
And the room was dusty,
full of garbage, not
even having a bed.
The only shining place was this
concrete floor where she
kick her legs and polished
that place.
And she was crying probably
for hours, here
eyes were red shot.
I thought she was going
to go blind.
That was my first day.
I lost the parents
who raised me.
I lost the parents who bore
me, and I became surrogate
mother to my little sister.
Then little did I know, Cultural
Revolution would last
for 10 years.
And I was in that ghetto, and
one room was no bed, no
bathroom, no wash basin,
for the next 10 years.
I've gone through a lot
of atrocity that you
will see in the book.
And then when I was 10 years
old, my sister was thrown into
a water canal outside
the wall.
And I jumped in to
try to save her.
I did save her, but I
didn't spare myself.
I was gang-raped by a group
of teenagers, broken,
cut up with a knife.
I still have 40 stitches
on my body.
Almost died.
But the physical injury was not
the most hurtful thing.
What was most hurtful was the
emotional abuse that followed.
At 10, I really didn't
understand anything.
I just thought I was
beaten badly.
But the rumor went around, and
I had a nickname, Broken
Shoes, which means that you are
so worn out that nobody
would want you.
So at 10, I was a
ruined woman.
And I had no adults to
turn to, I had no
psychologist to talk to.
I have no one to help me.
And many times, I thought
about dying.
I thought about this life
is not worth living.
But I had this little sister
that I have to take care of.
I couldn't just die.
I have responsibilities.
I think if I didn't have her, I
probably would have treat my
life much lighter.
So let me force forward to end
of Cultural Revolution and
then that was literally
12 years later.
China reopened university
in 1977.
And I studied to try
to pass national
exam to go into college.
I did pass, I do go
into college.
I was known as the girl whose
lights never turned off.
My life turned around, China
start to change.
When I was in college, I studied
Chinese literature.
I actually wanted to be
astronaut, but I didn't have a
choice, so I went to study
Chinese literature.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Close enough.
PING FU: Yeah, definitely.
So kind of the last semester
before I graduate, I thought I
was going to go to graduate
school, so I
went to do a thesis.
And China was imposing one child
policy, and I heard that
there was widespread killing
of baby girls in the
countryside.
So I decided to choose
that as a topic.
And that research being aired
in some of Chinese newspaper
where Chinese government was
calling for stop killing, but
that was the first documentation
from China that
admitted widespread killing
was happening.
And that news being picked up by
international newspaper and
UN posts sanction for human
rights violation.
So this was an embarrassment
for the new government.
At the time, Deng Xiaoping has
already taken over China.
Culture Revolution was over.
So this was an embarrassment to
the new government, and I
got in trouble and got
thrown in jail.
But that was only three days.
I was lucky that Deng Xiaoping
had asked what
happened to the reporter?
And they said, well, we
throw her in jail.
And he said, why?
This is not Cultural
Revolution anymore.
But he didn't give any other
instructions, so nobody knew
what to do with me.
And I was let out and then two
weeks later, I was given a
passport and told to leave the
country and never to come back
again, and not to file political
asylum because my
parents and my sister
were in China.
And I applied many university,
many countries, and I end up
in United States.
So your question is, how did
I live a life like that and
remain to see good
and to be kind.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Yes,
preservation of goodness.
PING FU: The preservation
with goodness.
So when I was a little, my
uncle, who I thought was my
father, had taught me many of
those human principles.
He told me that you don't do
things to other people that--
you don't want to treat other
people not the way how you
want to be treated.
He also told me that if you
are straight, you're not
worried about your
shadow is not.
And another thing that he had
me memorize is what's called
three friends of winter, and
bamboo is one of it, which is
what I wrote in my book.
And he told me that Ping, you
need to be bamboo, bending
with prevailing wind,
but never breaking.
And when I was going through
Cultural Revolution, I know
that if I don't focus
on goodness, then I
couldn't live my day.
So even in the darkest time,
there are human kindness from
different places.
I would find food left
out at my door.
Even though people don't dare
to be associated with us,
people were secretly
trying to help us.
There would be beauty always in
the ugliness, if you wanted
to seek for it.
I also found being good helps
me to survive, because when
you're good to others, it makes
it very hard for others
to be cruel to you.
So I just continued
focus on that.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Thank you.
So you came to America after
surviving kidnapping.
I remember readying that you
came only knowing three words
of English, which is hello,
help, and thank you.
PING FU: Very useful.
Three words.
CHADE-MENG TAN: You
should have also
added where's the toilet.
That's what I would've added.
And you came basically
crippled in language.
And then when you went to
graduate school, you switched
over to computer science.
And what you say was because you
realized mistakenly at the
time you were told that
computer science is a
different language, and that
you think it seems I'm
crippled in English, but if I
learn a new language, then
I'll be on a fair, level
playing field.
For those of you wondering why
all the Chinese immigrants are
software engineers--
[LAUGHTER]
PING FU: That's the reason.
CHADE-MENG TAN: There's
the secret.
What is even more fascinating
was that you went to class--
you were in a master's class in
computer science, and you
went to college not knowing
the basic mathematical
concepts like fractions.
And you wrote that you saw a
professor writing on the
blackboard numbers and then line
between, you were like
what's that?
So how was it like back then
to be in that situation?
PING FU: That's a very
good question.
So like Meng said, I came here,
I thought I was going to
study comparative literature.
My English was too poor.
And I can't study science
because I didn't go through
K-12 education.
I asked around, and somebody
said, oh yeah, there's a new
field called computer science.
And I said, what's that?
They said, well, it's man-made
language and you learn that to
make stuff.
I said, oh great.
I'm good with language and
I know how to make stuff.
And that's how I got into
computer science.
And because I didn't go through
formal education, I
didn't study mathematics in
classroom, when I went to
study computer science,
the first
class I took was calculus.
I was OK with the new
concept when the
professor was teaching.
If it's new, I can follow.
And when he put fractions on the
blackboard, I'd just never
seen anything like that.
And when I asked the professor,
he said, go back to
high school.
And I took it very literally.
I went to get high
school math.
I couldn't find it.
I went back to get middle
school class.
I couldn't find it.
I found it on second
grade math book.
So I actually borrowed entire
math book from first grade to
high school, and study at
night and study calculus
during the day.
And the smart student in the
class said Ping, you really
don't need that much.
You just go get a calculator.
As long as you understand the
concept, rest of the things
you can use calculator.
That was very helpful.
Back then, we actually don't
really have computer.
Yet today, you can
do anything.
But that also tells you like you
can learn a lot of things
even if you didn't have it.
And that's what I did.
I didn't study everything
in the book.
I just went to look for
whatever I needed.
And plus calculator plus asking
people, and got by.
First semester, I almost
failed my math class.
But by the second semester,
the professor thought-- a
second math class, not the
first second semester.
The second calculus,
I think it was
multi-variable calculus.
The professor thought that I was
the sister of the Olympic
math champion.
I thought I arrived.
CHADE-MENG TAN: That's
fascinating.
Thank you.
PING FU: So one point about your
question is, from time to
time, I would feel like I'm the
most stupid person in the
room, even though a lot
of people think
I'm wickedly smart.
Because often, I would have
people talking in the room and
I was sitting there and knowing
I was the only thing
have absolutely no clue what
they're talking about.
There's just no context
in back of my head.
And in some way, it's good
because I have to learn so I
have this infinite curiosity.
And it also keep me humble no
matter how smart I could be.
But I constantly feel I have
this stupidity in me.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Speaking
about humble--
so let's fast forward
to today.
And today, you are one of the
most admired people around,
maybe in the world.
You are very successful.
You are successful entrepreneur
and engineer.
You were named the entrepreneur
of the year.
And you give advice to
President Obama.
I also give advice, but
the difference is
that he invited you.
He didn't invite me.
I'm just kidding.
I just spam your email.
PING FU: He comes to you.
CHADE-MENG TAN: I'm
just kidding.
So you are amazingly successful,
up to including
being a presidential adviser.
So how do you feel about your
success today, especially in
the context of your
overall life?
PING FU: That's a
good question.
I think originally, I did get my
head blown up a little big
like balloons.
But what I realized, success is
kind of like balloon-- they
disappear very quickly.
It's kind of like raise
and getting a salary.
First, day you get excited.
Next day, you forget about it.
So I don't really think about
success, because I don't even
know how to define it.
I think about contribution.
I think it's easy to think
about contribution.
And the contribution can be for
yourself, for your loved
ones, for your community, for
the people who you know, or
for people who you don't know.
And you don't have to contribute
everything every
day, but if you can contribute
something some days, that
makes everybody feel good.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Thank you.
I like how you define your
success as a contribution
rather than--
PING FU: Rather than
a success.
CHADE-MENG TAN: --source
of glory.
So I have to ask you
about your shoes.
These shoes are very cool.
So let's tell everybody
about your shoes.
PING FU: So this is
a 3D printed shoe.
It actually is a MoMA piece, and
it's displayed in Modern
Museum of Art in New York.
And it's a mashup
of many things.
So the top of my shoe has
Google logo, airplanes,
chains, guns, anything.
You can just put it on.
The bottom of the shoe is
actually a play on materials.
So instead of being solid,
you put a lot of geometry
structure in there to
make it both strong,
lightweight, and flexible.
And then the material
is linen.
So linen is biodegradable
unlike plastic, and it's
incredibly strong because
it's natural fiber.
And then the shape
of the shoe--
let me take it off-- is
the arch of my feet.
And also, we have done fluid
dynamic to make sure that it
is fitting not only to the shape
of my feet, but also how
I walk, my body weight, and
whether or not my feet tilt
from in or out.
So this is the same principle
being made before Lady Gaga
shoe if you're wondering how he
could be able to dance on
the stage with 12 inches
heel without falling.
It's because it's perfectly
balanced to her
body and her movement.
I started Geomagic to try to
create software that produced
one of the kind product that
start with us, the person, not
building a product start
with a product.
And if you don't know about 3D
printing, 3D printing is very
similar to 2D printing.
It uses the same
inkjet nozzles.
Instead of coming
out with ink, it
comes out with material.
And it prints one
layer at a time.
If you just take one layer,
it's just like 2D printing
other than it's depositing
material.
And then it use various curing
method to harden the material.
Then you do it one
layer at a time.
Therefore, you can build very
intricate internal structures,
because you've build it
one layer at a time.
I think in very short distance
to future, you will all have a
3D printer at home.
And you would all have a
3D scanner at home or
3D camera at home.
That would be really, really
cool, because if you think
about publishing industry, the
desktop publishing completely
changed how publishing
is being done.
And desktop manufacturing or
desktop fabrication will
completely change how
things are made.
This can go from airplane parts
to Invisalign to shoes,
even to the bioprinting like
we already today can print
bone scaffold, organs, leather
without killing
animals, meat maybe.
We can produce [INAUDIBLE]
proteins without having to
have slaughter houses and
erasing costs that taking up a
lot of energy.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Wow.
That is cool.
[INAUDIBLE].
PING FU: Here's the Bugdroids.
Those are all created
by kids from school.
They take your standard Android
figurine and then they
put design on it and then push
a button, gets printed.
CHADE-MENG TAN: So when you
went out to do this, you
wanted to do personal factories,
PF, your initials.
So did you feel that you
achieved personal factories
yet, or is that in the future?
PING FU: I think now it's
at the taking off point.
When I started Geomagic--
that's about 15 years ago--
I saw a demonstration from 3D
Systems founder Chuck Hull.
He was showing a machine called
stereolithography machine.
And today, we call them
3D printer or additive
manufacturing or personal
factory.
It blew my mind, so I said,
I want to do this.
And that was at internet high.
Everybody was--
Jack Welch was talking about
destroyyourself.com.
And I worked with Marc
Andreessen and started Mosaic,
become Netscape.
Everybody was surprised.
Why would you start a
manufacturing company?
It's not sexy.
It takes 15 years, and now it's
the hottest industry.
CHADE-MENG TAN: There are two
things I really appreciate
having you talk about
in the context of
being a business leader.
And it's not success.
It's not even contribution.
One of the things I really
appreciate you talking about
is this quote.
It is all about love.
And the other is very similar
to the first thing, which is
you always try to make the
compassionate choice.
You've got two choices.
You always made a choice that's
more compassionate.
And in your words, you say,
choose always choosing to love
and to understand.
So can you talk more about love
and compassion in the
context of business
leadership?
PING FU: OK.
So in terms of a business, one
of the things I said about the
business in the 2000s, which is
after internet crash come
and everybody said this is an
incredibly difficult time to
run business, is what I
observed, a Renaissance
movement of social consciousness
for business.
And I do think that down market
contributed to that.
And Google is a great company
that embodies social
consciousness and business
can live together.
So I remember a lot of time, I
get MBA student come in to
interview and they would ask me,
what's your exit strategy?
I would say the exit sign
is clearly marked.
And the people would ask me,
what is your goal for next
five years?
Where you want Geomagic to be?
I said I only want one thing,
which is people come in to
work here, they love what
they do and they love
who they work with.
And that's why I say it's
all about love.
If you don't love what you do,
you're wasting your life.
If you don't know who you're
working with, you're not
enjoying what you're doing.
And love and business are
so intimately related.
I cannot see any great companies
doesn't love their
people and their people doesn't
love their company.
So that's that.
And then to come back to talk
about compassion and
understanding--
and this is a part of--
I've been searching business.
And startup business and big
business are quite different.
People talk about business
models, they talk how to run
business, management principles,
and all of those
being written a lot.
But I wake up in the morning, I
tell myself every day I want
to practice compassion
and understanding.
I go around, talk to employees,
or I go outside to
try to understand in the society
what problem can we
solve and what value
can we create?
And that's the understanding
part.
As a CEO, my job is to
bring in outside
world into the company.
And no business and service
should exist if they are not
there to solve problems.
So my job is to bring outside
world into the company.
But I also need to fundamentally
understand what
we can actually do to help the
world, or what kind of talent
our people have, or what they
can create, and also how we
can understand each other, how
they understand a problem.
And every day, I tell myself
that's the two things I need
to practice.
If I can practice that,
I can help to
create a great business.
Whatever the management or
business principle people want
to bring in or people think
that's good, that's fine.
You said at Google, if
it's fun, we do it.
CHADE-MENG TAN: I think I said
because it's fun or because
it's cool is good enough
reason to do anything.
PING FU: Good enough reason
to do anything, yes.
CHADE-MENG TAN: So if you're
running a bigger company,
let's say something the size of
Google, 30,000 employees,
will you still be employing
the same philosophy?
And if so, how do you
imagine doing that?
PING FU: A very good question.
With startup company, because
startup company is in the
place to search a repeatable and
scalable business, they're
not in known market, they're
not having known customers.
Larger company have a known
market and known customers,
and also with a small startup
company, you know every one.
You don't need a
lot of process.
So you could actually trust
your people and hope that
there's going to be good
business to come.
When you become Google's size,
you can't just trust and hope.
You really need to do trust
and track, right?
So that's where the big data,
the measurement comes in.
I would still practice the
same compassion and
understanding.
But maybe I need to understand
different things.
Maybe I need the tools to help
me with data to understand
things rather than just
talking to people.
That's not enough.
But I would still do the
same philosophy.
And it just needs different
tools to help and to achieve
the same understanding
and compassion.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Very cool.
So right now, Ping, what
do you want to be
when you grow up?
PING FU: Great.
It's all about love.
[LAUGHTER]
PING FU: So I am design next
stage of my life, I think.
It would be great at every
stage, you can say what do you
want to be when you grow up Not
very long ago, I met this
fortune teller from India.
And he was telling me that he
had read many, many people's--
he reads hand, including Dalai
Lama and Deng Xiaoping and so
on so forth.
I don't know that's
true or not, but I
just assume it's true.
And so he ready my hand
and he said to me--
and this was actually
five years ago.
He says, when you grow up,
you will be a teacher.
And so this may be
what I will do.
And I don't actually think
I would be a teacher.
I think I probably will be a
midwife to give birth for good
ideas or good things that
come from other people.
That's probably what I'll do.
I'll be midwife.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Cool.
And teacher at the same time.
So I want to leave about half
an hour for you to ask Ping
some questions.
But do we have a mic for--
STEPHANIE: Yeah.
CHADE-MENG TAN: OK.
So while Stephanie's passing out
a mic, I want to ask you
one more question, which is
Ping, how are you going to
save the world?
And how do I and how
do we, Google, help
you save the world?
PING FU: Wow, that's
a big question.
So when I started Geomagic, I
wanted to save the world by
combining hand craftsmanship
with IT technology.
And I wanted to bring back much
of what we human have
created in thousands of years,
the treasures, the memory, the
collective treasure, to bring
it to the future generation.
I feel that's our
responsibility.
And I still feel that this is
the space I want to be in and
this is what I will do
to save the world.
From a Google point of view, I
always admired Google Search.
But I do have a request.
I know you do incredible
job in organizing world
information and delivering
needed
information to me in my fingertip.
But there's still remaining
in the text and
image and 2D world.
And I want you to help to create
search information
which will search
shapes in 3D.
Say if I want save the world to
deliver customized product
to you, customized medicine to
you as a human, but how do we
search all those things that
are not just text and image
and files that display on
flatscreen or can be printed
on flat piece of paper?
And use that to create whether
or not I broke my bone, I want
to customize the cast to be
made, that I can put it on.
Or if I want to buy a pair of
shoes, that shoe doesn't have
to be made.
I can just upload my shape
of my feet and
say, this is the shape.
This is what I want, and
make one for me, right?
So the search is a part of the
product design itself.
The search actually is embedded
in what I want.
It's not advertisement.
The value is embedded before the
product is even developed.
Why that's important--
today, we produce 80% of goods
that's never needed.
If you produce 100%,
you sell 20%.
Other 80% are more
or less wasted.
Either reduce the price
or whatever.
So that's one thing.
And then we also ship
them across the sea,
which is not green.
We also use a lot
of [INAUDIBLE].
And we waste a lot of time,
and we're very frustrated.
So I think if the search
can be embedded
in the design itself--
and imagine in the future,
everything you buy or
everything you use-- doesn't
even have to be you buy.
Everything you use in terms of
product is a software code.
And then your search
is embedded in
that software code.
CHADE-MENG TAN: So for those of
you want to help Ping save
the world, please feel
free to talk to her.
One more comment I want to make
before we pass the mic is
what you said earlier reminded
me of something.
There was a four star general
in the US Army whose name
escapes me right now.
But his advice for people who
asking for advice about life,
his advice is don't stop
falling in love.
For a four star general to say
that, that blew my mind.
And so what you just said
reminded me of that.
And with that, anybody want
to ask a question?
The mic is over there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming here.
Your story's very
inspirational.
I do want you to talk about the
times when it was not so
easy to look at world so
positively, and it was not so
easy to think about compassion
or love.
So how did you pick
yourself up?
And it's easier to say that
there's a bright side and
there is love in the darkest
moment, and there's probably
something, right?
So how do you pick
yourself up?
And when you see [INAUDIBLE]
who are struggling with those
kind of things, what do you
say to them?
PING FU: So that's a
very good question.
When the world is cruel to you,
when the things are dark,
when you're really in a
rat hole, how do you
pick yourself up?
I think there are two
things at play.
One part I like to say that I
may be born with good genes.
We do all have our DNA and
everybody gets born with
different kind of personality.
The other part is, I did find
that sometimes, when you go
through very deep atrocity and
you come out on the other
side, it gives you
that optimism.
Because for me, every time
the door is closed,
something else happens.
So I believe behind every closed
door, there's open
space because my life tells
me, teaches that.
When I don't have enough
English, I
study computer science.
Look where I am today.
When I got kick out of China,
I did not know what kind of
life I would have in America.
Look where I am today.
But in those dark moment, part
of it is also I did that for
survival because if I'm
not going to be
kind, I'll get beaten.
So I have no choice.
But when I was kind,
I find other people
returning the kindness.
And the other thing is, I did
not have any right back then.
I was forced in stage to scream
I was nobody and I'm
worse than the [INAUDIBLE]
beneath your feet.
I was eight.
So after I said that many time,
I start to believe that.
I start to believe I
did not have right.
When you believe you don't have
a right, you're pretty
vulnerable.
And when I was vulnerable, I
find other people help me.
So sometimes it isn't that
you're strong, you're
successful, you're great,
that you see goodness.
A lot of time it is when
you're in the dirt.
When you really need help, that
little bit kindness that
people show you become
this big.
And that's what I grab on.
That's what I just
latch to it.
And then I also truly
understand how
important that is to me.
And that's why I practice
compassion,
because I've been there.
I've been in those places
where that little bit
compassion saved my life.
I don't even know the person who
show me that knows that.
When I landed in America,
I had $80 travelers
check in San Francisco.
The American man behind me gave
$5 to the ticket counter
so that I could guy my ticket
to go to university.
I have no money.
I don't know for him $5
mean a lot to him.
But for me, that was
a life to me.
So I learned through my life,
when in doubt, always err on
the side of generosity.
AUDIENCE: So how do you feel all
the trauma that you had as
a child, how did that affect you
adversely when I guess you
grew up [INAUDIBLE]
relationships and everything,
because you obviously had very
unusual relationships as a
child, losing most of your
relatives, and then coming
here not knowing anybody.
And obviously that maybe had
some adverse effects.
And I know there's a lot of
debate about kids with tough
childhoods, how that affects
them later in life, positively
and negatively.
Some people say actually
there's very little
correlation between what
happened to them as a child
and what happens to them as an
adult in their relationships.
And other schools of thought
say it has a
very profound effect.
So how did it affect
you personally?
PING FU: So I think Nietzche
said what doesn't break you
makes you stronger.
And I do believe practice makes
you stronger like sports
or programming.
I just have a lot more
practice over a
certain skill set.
But then I like what you said
that it could also affect you
a different way.
I do not wish anyone to
live the life I have.
I do not believe that by living
through the type of
life that I lived made
me successful.
I don't think there's
a causality.
But I do believe that because
I lived through this kind of
life, I overpracticed
certain things.
For example, by not going to
school, I overpracticed
self-learning.
And self-learning is a very
important aspect of
entrepreneurship because there's
no book to teach you
how to be a CEO.
I practiced how to deal with
adversity which helped me to
help the company to survive,
for example.
But there's also the normal
human relationship.
I didn't have it.
So maybe I could be overly
critical or less sensitive to
other people.
I don't think whatever
is a big deal.
And that's not right.
This is why I'm practicing
compassion every day or
practicing understanding every
day because I feel that's
important because I have
a different context.
I saw other people grew up.
And this became more
important.
when I became a mother, because
my daughter grew up in
completely protected environment
and never know a
day of atrocity.
So how do I bring up a daughter
who's just had
everything and make sure that
she will become independent?
What I realized is it is not
the what happened to you
that's important.
It is how you deal with the
emotional intensity when
things happen to you.
So for example, something could
be very simple, would
give my daughter this much
emotional intensity, would
give me nothing.
And it would take a lot
to give me this
big emotional intensity.
But emotional intelligence or
fluency is the same skill.
It's independent of the event.
But it is dependent on how
you react to it and how
you think about it.
So that's my realization.
It's we all have our own
response to life event to us.
And we can control what life
is going to throw at us.
Life is messy.
Life is going to throw
anything at anybody.
Everybody's life is a story.
So it's how we deal with it.
That's important.
And that's what I try to express
in this book also.
CHADE-MENG TAN: So
how do you do it?
How do you teach young people,
teenagers, about
dealing with emotions?
PING FU: So it's not about not
to have emotion, which I
actually have very little.
I kind of try to learn to have
emotion whereas people around
me, are kind of like, whoa,
I saw this drama.
But over the time, I feel like I
need to have some drama too,
otherwise I'm not feeling it.
I need to feel it.
So it is actually more of--
it's more of how you
react to it.
You wrote a lot in your book
about how to deal with
emotion, how to think about
it, which I think is very,
very helpful.
You have a lot of practical
advice that I need
to learn from you.
And I'm kind of coming from
a different side.
People living normal upbringing,
have loving
parents and loving spouse and
loving friends may have a lot
of emotions that they
have to deal with.
So they need a Google search
yourself kind of help.
I'm kind of on the other side.
I'm kind of like I haven't
seen fractions
and I have too little.
So I buy books every
time I see people.
Like I bought all Rumi's
poetry on love.
Last night, I went to
A Year of Love, A
Night of Rumi dinner.
I find it fascinating because
I was trying to learn how to
develop my emotion versus
managing the emotion.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
First of all, thank you for
sharing your stories.
Quick question for you is,
looking back at your life, if
you think of a personal decision
you made that was
under your control, is there
something that you can think
of that you would change or take
back that you personally
had a choice and control on
if you had a chance today?
PING FU: That's a very
good question.
What I come to realization is
what happened to me, I have
absolutely no control.
But what I do have control is
how I feel about it and what
is my experience to it.
So even bad things happen
to you, you could have a
different experience, and you
can feel differently.
So those two things I feel
like I do have control.
So I learned to really
appreciate every day that
comes to me where I pretty much
have total control over
what kind of day I have.
And I want to have an
interesting day.
I'm not saying I just want
to have a happy day.
All emotions are interesting,
just like food,
you want all taste.
I saw a question over there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
survived adversity to say that
there was one moment where
they felt themselves become an
adult, whether it was death of
a parent, whether--
you've lived through so much.
Is there one moment where you
felt yourself losing childhood
and become an adult?
Or was it just a series of very
harsh nightmarish event?
PING FU: So at eight years old
when I lost both set of
parents and became the surrogate
mother to my
daughter, I was forced to be
adult in that instance.
I spent my life to try to be
child rather than adult.
But I think my adulthood
is overdeveloped.
So I'm trying to
work that away.
CHADE-MENG TAN: So how are you
going to be a child again?
PING FU: When I get old, I'll
be child regardless
[INAUDIBLE]
my friends going to deteriorate,
and I'm going to
depend on other people.
I usually say at the two ends of
your life, you're a child.
And that's why it's so important
for us to show
compassion to older people,
because they
become child again.
AUDIENCE: First, congratulations
on the sale to
3D Systems.
I just saw that.
Question for you [INAUDIBLE]
how you planned a career and
when you decided to change it,
how did you decide when you were
coming out of Mosaic and
starting up with [INAUDIBLE]
starting up on 3D printing
[INAUDIBLE]
when you were debating how to
make these decisions, how do
you decide and teach yourself
everything about an entirely
different industry and get
up to speed on it?
And you said you learned
to learn.
But how did you learn
to learn?
PING FU: That's a very
good question.
So I do believe that you--
not everybody like to change
their life all the time.
If you spent all your life
to do same thing, that's
perfectly fine.
You can perfect something.
Like I was having this
conversation with Yo-Yo Ma not
too long ago.
He become the best cello
player musician and
everything.
He envies me changing my
life every 10 years.
But I envy him to be
this grand master.
So it's perfectly fine to be
incredibly good at one thing.
And I like to change my life
every 10 or some years because
I feel like life is like
a mountain range.
At every peak, the view
is different.
But if you like that kind of
life, one of the things I like
to leave with you is you
can't always go up.
You have to go down to
go to another peak.
So I did go through job to job
to take a pay cut, to take
different positions.
But what I pursue is
a different view.
And you also don't know if that
view is really the view
you thought it's going to be.
So first thing is, you need to
know who you are, yourself,
the authentic self.
I know I like change,
I like variety.
I know I view life as
a mountain range.
So I know who authentic
self is.
That's one.
The second thing that you need
to know is what you are
passionate about.
You could be passionate
about something that
you're great at.
Then you can be grand
master of something.
You could also be passionate
about something that you're
truly interested, but you don't
know anything about it.
Then you go learn about it.
So that's kind of what I decided
when I make change and
how and what.
CHADE-MENG TAN: It sounds to
me like the previous thing,
that you're always doing
what you love.
PING FU: I always do
what I love, yes.
That's why I say it's
all about love.
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
Ping, for coming.
I think your courage to deal
with the challenge of that is
truly amazing.
I have two questions.
One is, how's your sister
doing these days?
I hope she's doing well.
And the second one is,
do you travel back
to China these days?
Do you find it difficult with
all those miserable memories?
And how do you deal with it?
PING FU: Very good question.
So good thing is my sister
is doing very well.
I brought her to United States
two years after I came to
United States.
She literally went to depression
when I left since I
brought her up as our mother.
And she is entrepreneur
herself.
She studied architecture.
And now, she's doing specialty
retail in Scottsdale, Arizona.
She has two very great
shops over there.
So that's my sister.
Second question was--
AUDIENCE: Travel
back to China.
PING FU: Oh, travel
I did not go back to China for
10 years until I become US
citizen because I didn't feel
safe to go back to China.
I did go back to China after
I became US citizen.
The very first time I went back
to China, I felt lost,
because China has completely
changed and it wasn't the
China that I remembered.
And it was speaking of '90s when
China was kind of in the
chaos of economic development.
I came back and really just felt
I'm American now, and I
wasn't going to go back.
But that again changed
when China
developed and I developed.
So when I started Geomagic over
the time, I actually now
have a subsidiary in China.
And also, when China come to the
global scene, when China
become economic powerhouse,
people ask me about China.
I have a Chinese face.
It doesn't matter
what I think.
People see me, they ask me about
China, I go OK, I better
go back to study China.
So I spent quite a bit of time
to study Chinese history,
because now the books is also
available, more objective
material is available.
I almost got a Ph.D. in that.
So I studied Chinese history,
Chinese literature, Chinese
politics, economics, everything
just so that when
people ask me China,
I can say something
intelligent about it.
Now, there is one thing about
not going to school is that
you never know when to stop.
There's no exam and you
don't really know
when you know enough.
And then my stack of book,
I called them my stack of
[INAUDIBLE] just keep growing
and shrinking like this.
So when I do that, I changed
my view of China because I
really cannot judging a country
with more than 2,000
years of history with my
15 years atrocity or my
experience.
I just happened to live
in the darkest
period of modern China.
It's kind of like you can't
define Germany with Holocaust.
You can't define China with
Cultural Revolution.
AUDIENCE: As soon as I tell my
wife about your shoes, I know
she's going to want them.
So the question is, where are
we today compared to when do
we think those type of shoes and
such will be available to
mainstream consumers at an
affordable cost so that people
have them readily available
in their houses and such?
PING FU: So it depend on how
many Google dollars you have
in your pocket.
And depend on whether or not
Google subsidize shoes like
they subsidize books.
You can buy those shoes today.
We have a storefront called
Freshfiber which is the brand
name for those shoes and
also iPhone cases.
And you can also find them on
this site called cubify.com.
So the 3D Systems
little personal
printer today is $1,200.
It's called a Cube.
It's kind of like cubism.
And then the website is
called cubify.com.
The shoes currently is at
a price about $200.
So it depends on the Google
dollars you define, whether or
not it's affordable or not.
It's kind of in the price
of Nordstrom.
And if you want to customize,
it's still less than $1,000.
I know shoes in Barney cost
more than that they
don't have on sales.
And also your question, when
does it will reach consumer
massive level.
My prediction would be
within five years.
CHADE-MENG TAN: If no more
question, I have one last
question for you, Ping.
For the past hour, if there's
only one thing the audience
brings back from this past hour,
what do you want that
one thing to be?
PING FU: One thing for
the audience--
CHADE-MENG TAN: To bring home.
PING FU: --to bring home.
CHADE-MENG TAN: Beside
those shoes.
PING FU: Message, right,
not shoes?
OK.
I would say remember life
is a mountain range.
CHADE-MENG TAN: My friends,
"Bend, Not Break," available
in Google Play and
major bookstores.
And my friend, Ping Fu.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]